there's some articles that have appeared
on the internet and there's been some
other videos I've seen people create
about Pope Francis and this question has
to do with he was visiting with some
teens at school and he responded to a
question that someone asked about how to
deal with people of other faiths and
people who were atheist saying and his
response was that Christians should
never attempt to convert a person from
one belief to another and anyone who
does that is not truly Christian now how
do you react to that comment and is that
a biblical belief sure let me give you a
little background of the question that
was asked to Pope Francis his response
and then a biblical response he was it
was on December 20 he was giving some
lectures to a group of high school
students and these one of the high
school students asked that question
about conversion how do you relate to
those who are not of the Christian faith
or unbelievers it was at that point that
Pope Francis said that you live your
life and live a godly life and but
certainly don't try to convert them and
certainly don't share the gospel with
them because that would not be the
Christian thing to do he uses the
argument there of the Christians and as
they were trying to convert Muslims and
says that Christians when they were
trying to convert Muslims threatened
them with death I'm not sure that that
statement is even historically factual
if it is it simply is what we would call
certainly not in harmony with God's will
for anybody to force anybody else and we
could agree with the Pope in the
standpoint of the fact that our lives
should be a testimony there's no
question there but now here's the but
certainly our lives should be a test
but it's not either/or the Bible is very
very clear if you look at it let me give
you some Bible passages that are too
clear to be misunderstood
the bible does urge us to go out and
preach the gospel it urges us to share
the gospel not simply in the way we live
but in what we proclaim Matthew chapter
28 says Jesus says go therefore and make
disciples of all nations he doesn't
simply say go and live a kind gracious
life although we are to do that don't
misunderstand me but it says go
therefore and make disciples of all
nations baptizing in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
teaching them to all to observe all
things whatever I've commanded you and
lo I'm with you always even to the end
of the age so in every generation God's
people are to go out there to proclaim
the Gospel they're to see men and women
come to Christ in mark chapter 16 and
verse 16 it says he who believes it says
verse 15 he said go into all the world
and preach the gospel to every creature
not simply live it but preach it he who
believes and is baptized will be saved
but he who does not believe will be
condemned
so hear Christ Himself urges us to go
preach the gospel Acts chapter one these
passages are just too powerful to to
overlook Acts chapter one verse 8 it
says this but what you shall receive
power when the Holy Spirit has come upon
you and you shall be witnesses to me in
Jerusalem Judea Samaria the ends of the
earth so the first thing that we want to
say is this yes we are to live a godly
life certainly we are to reflect the
image of Jesus to others our life does
speak the life that Christ lives spoke
but that does not mean in any way shape
or form that we should not openly
proclaim the gospel and lead people to
Jesus Christ so from that perspective
now from that perspective we would have
to respectfully disagree with the Pope's
concept the Pope's statement to that
child that student that we should not
proclaim the gospel in conversion now
let me tell you where this is leading
it's leading to what we would call anti
conversion laws we see some of those
conversion laws that in various
countries we see some in Muslim
countries there's some Hindu areas where
they're anti conversion laws now what is
an anti conversion law it's a law that
puts restrictions on the Liberty to
proclaim the Gospel as Christ said and
it puts at times fines and punishment
upon those who do that once you go the
direction of anti conversion laws you
restrict religious liberty and if the
state passes anti conversion laws it
restricts the freedom to proclaim the
gospel and to carry out the gospel
Commission as Jesus has said once we
restrict religious liberty once that
religious liberty is taken from us that
will lead to other freedoms and other
liberties being taken away so the
biggest danger I see personally in the
Pope's what the Pope said is not only
does it misunderstand the gospel but it
leads us down a road where a church and
state could mutually agree to pass anti
conversion laws that would be a step in
the direction mat of restricting
religious liberty which i think is
really dangerous
you